bonsoir france lorsque les maîtres ce
merci d'être avec nous un duel
fratricide on qu'un pour un candidat
moins populaire faut bien le dire que
marcus soeder l'affrontement va t-il
laissé des traces qui aimait blement
surtout c'est un candidat qui est assez
atypique qui n'est pas tout à fait dans
la ligne habituelle d'un parti aussi
traditionnel que la cd ou c'est un
journaliste d'origine c'est quelqu'un
qui est venu un petit peu sur le tard
sous tu il est vrai par angela merkel et
qui avait soutenu en gala merkel sur sa
politique en matière en faveur des
immigrants ça c'est très important pour
comprendre qu'il a un petit peu une
certaine forme d'opposition à
l'intérieur d'une partie des cadres de
la population du parti de manière
générale qui considèrent qu'ils n'ont
qu'un petit peu de stabilité qu'il n'est
peut-être pas suffisamment convaincants
comme pouvait l'être par exemple marcus
slaughter qui est le patron de la
bavière qui est un land extrêmement
important et qu'il y avait une forme de
popularité beaucoup plus grande
les choix que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on connaît le
casting de l'élection qui va avoir lieu
en septembre
c'est à dire qu'on connaît les deux
personnalités qui vont pouvoir
l'une ou l'autre devenir chancelier
d'allemagne fédérale après après angela
merkel
et ça c'est très important parce que
d'une part la cd ou qui part en ordre
dispersé avec une certaine forme de
division va avoir en face d'elle un
parti qui est complètement unifiée qui
est le parti des verts est un parti qui
a su mettre à sa tête une personnalité
je pense par exemple qu'en france on
n'aime pas beaucoup les têtes qui
dépassent yannick jadot en sait quelque
chose
mais en allemagne celle inverse en
allemagne les verts ont su pratiquer une
véritable démocratie dans lequel émane
une personnalité qui elle n'est
absolument pas contesté et donc on peut
considérer qu'un dalena berlocq a de
grandes chances effectivement peut-être
pas arrivé à l'agencé dry mais d'arrivée
certainement deuxième position
aujourd'hui clairement cette ancienne
championne de trampoline il faut le
préciser
est-ce qu'elle a tout de même autant de
chance aujourd'hui que son futur
adversaire conservateur un peu moins de
chance c'est vrai parce que les sondages
récents la met en deuxième position et
on voit encore mal ça serait une
véritable révolution d'ailleurs s'il est
allé vers arrivée en tête mais si les 10
millions qui sont au sein de la cd ou cs
ou se renforcent et si les rancoeurs sur
renforce effectivement toutes les
chansons là parce que davantage dans l
ena berlocq
c'est que c'est une femme qui a de la
personnalité qui sait ce qu'elle veut et
qui est soutenu en plus partout son
parti qui fait un seul bloc ce qui n'est
pas le cas en france puis en allemagne
c'est une réalité et donc la possibilité
d'avoir une chancelière verte en
allemagne n'est pas tout à fait exclue
d'autant plus que même si l arrivée en
seconde position de manière assez serré
elle pourrait très bien constituer une
coalition avec le spd et les libéraux
pour effectivement devenir chancelier
donc cette possibilité il existe la
relève d'un gala merkel on imagine 16
ans au pouvoir va être difficile quel
que soit le nouvel élu qu'est-ce qui va
pouvoir peser dans le sens du futur
candidat
bon je crois que toute façon de les deux
candidats ces deux personnalités sont
toutes les deux des personnalités
centristes donc modérée inverse modérée
d'un côté et un conservateur modéré de
l'autre dans les deux cas il s'agit de
candidats qui sont profondément
européens se sont dits candidats qui
pigent suivront qui vous probablement la
politique existante européenne d'amitié
avec la france totalement mais des
candidats par exemple comme maddalena
averbukh elle remettrait directement en
cause le fameux gazoduc north stream qui
est directement en cours d'année par une
partie des allemands mais l'autre armin
laschet tu es quelqu'un qui est tout à
fait dans une tradition sociale le
démocrate chrétienne démocrate qu'on a
l'habitude et le voir mais peut-être
avec un style différent plus chaleureux
et c'est ce style chaleureux qui a fait
qu'il a probablement été mis sur orbite
par entre guéret
quel mais le problème maintenant c'est
qu'il va falloir convaincre l'opinion
allemande car sa popularité n'est pas
encore affirmer en allemagne sur quoi
vont se jouer ces législatives
on le sait comme en france il ya la
crise sanitaire qui est sûr dans tous
les esprits est sur toutes les lèvres
il ya d'autres thèmes qui vont
réellement pesé pour ces élections
oui bien sûr il ya des étapes de
l'avenir de l'énergie l'a bien la
politique verte pour l'allemagne
l'avenir effectivement de des
différentes énergies vertes possible
mais les l'immigration bien sûr reste
quand même un dossier important
la politique générale économique reste
un dossier important mais ça ne pourra
pas changer de manière énorme par contre
un parti comme la cd ou risquent de
souffrir d'une certaine manière assez
gravement des menaces enfin des
réputations de corruption qui a pu avoir
lieu chez certains membres du parti de
la cdo et ça ça peut peser effectivement
sur la cd ou pour ces élections
mais d'un autre côté pour anna lena
berlocq
c'est un parti vert qui est modéré je le
disais bien et donc qui est tout à fait
dans une optique de compromis et non pas
dans une optique idéologique que je
dirais et donc ça c'est un élément neuf
qui il va militer en faveur
effectivement d'une possibilité de
compromis et surtout de coalition parce
qu'il faut pas l'oublier
en allemagne ce sont en général les
coalitions qui arrivent au pouvoir
et ce n'est pas forcément un parti des
coalitions donc le sens de compromis est
important et effectivement françois paul
et métis il est important de préciser
pour ceux qui l'ignoreraient que les
verts allemands ne sont pas du tout les
verts français exactement on aime on
n'aime pas les têtes qui dépassent en
france mais en allemagne on aime les
têtes qui dépassent et merci françois
pour les métis d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir évoqué dans cette situation
après l'investiture
donc d'armes in l'achète pour la td ou
pour les prochaines législatives
allemandes merci à vous